one day I hope you find someone who
looks at you the same way that Griffith
looks at the subscribe button for the
new world review full of intense longing
and lost just thinking about all of that
regular berserk content being uploaded
straight into his YouTube feed that
would be living the dream
hello and welcome to the new old reveal
your source for everything anime and
manga and you know what today I'm in a
particular possession mood so I just
going to casually talk about one of the
more enduring questions of the series
which is how are we going to defeat
Griffith although that question does
admit the assume quite a lot so not only
are we going to delve into that but also
the general inquiry of will Griffith be
defeated and this is because despite
potentially being one of the most
despised characters in media Griffith or
femto whatever you prefer to call him
these days remains as quite possibly the
most captivating character in berserk
for me personally and it's kind of crazy
because I honestly don't like Griffith
but the respect he commands whenever he
appears on a page is undeniable he never
fails to secure my full attention and in
many ways I think you can look at
berserk from the perspective of this
being Griffith story being told from the
sidelines but a lot of his sheer
presence obviously spawns from the
depths of power that Griffith represents
as a member of God hand he is more or
less akin to the first part of that name
and compared with a large majority of
existence Griffiths power is
overwhelming and inevitable to the point
where quite frankly it would be a bit of
a sick joke to ever let one's mind
wander to the possibility of guts ever
managing to bring him down and securing
a traditional sense of revenge nor would
I personally expect for Zack to end in
that manner
however we are left with quite a
considerable amount of options some of
which really do stretch the concept of
defeat into some very intriguing areas
but before we delve too far into that we
will commence with the most literal
possible sense of the word defeat
meaning to overcome in terms of power
and the most straightforward approach to
take to this immediately would be to
ascent into a femto level of power and
there are a couple of different ways to
maybe go about this the first and more
outrageous one would be to have one of
our characters become a member of the
God Hand which the Fantasia Ark has made
technically possible through the idea
that time moves significantly slower in
a film so when we pop out who knows
maybe a good 200 or so years will of
passed and it will be time for another
initiate if there is indeed another one
or perhaps even a restart of the god
handcycle who knows about me but in any
case I don't specify who because it
doesn't Ness
early need to be guts and if anything
having guts go down such a path would
kind of destroy his narrative duality
with the Griffith character but I'm not
so sure if that would necessarily stop
someone like sake Casca from joining
their ranks and then using her newfound
abilities to exact sweet sweet revenge
upon femto it would rather sadly require
a sacrifice though which is probably the
only part about this idea that does kind
of fit with me actually because it would
be a classic slice of tragedy for I the
guts like Oscar to ascent I imagine that
they would need to sacrifice the other
and possibly even their whole little
cohort in fact that idea seems really
intriguing to put guts in a position
where he does get presented with the
same choice as Griffith except guts
doesn't go through with it
so I feel like this first idea is
certainly a most unlikely because when
given the opportunity I just cannot see
it being taken not like guts anyway
maybe Casca maybe there are other
avenues to pursue there I mean we do
have figures like the skull knight in
existence and there is a strong thread
tying guts to the potential fate of
ending up as a skull knight type
presence which on the one hand would
give him access to some pretty decent
power would it be enough power mmm
highly unlikely and once again there is
also that bit of a narrative barrier
because guts has been cast as a man
fighting against and defying fate so as
much as this and really the entire video
is completely speculation that would
lead me to believe that the answer to
this problem does not lie in a path that
we have already seen the ultimate
destination of simply becoming a member
of the god hand or following in the
footsteps of the skull Knight are all
too straightforward and in a way they're
more like giving in to fate so perhaps
we need to think of a twist on this and
if we are still focusing on overcoming
Griffith by the concept of power alone
then you know there are a collective
four figures who might just be able to
pull such a feat off being his other
godhand members this is quite a stretch
though because while Griffith obviously
does seem to be working on his own
volition and using his power to
accomplish his own desires that's not
necessarily different from the rest of
the group for the most part they seem to
act alone or at least that's what's LAN
would imply when she appeared in Kwai
Fong Plus to be perfectly honest
everything seems to be going according
to the ever-present causality and the
Great War of the astral world very much
seems to have only benefited or
progressed the ultimate purpose of this
group so it's very unlikely to see a
situation where they stand against
Griffith if anything I would say the
reverse is more likely because I can't
imagine a case where Falcom boy misuse
his boundless
ambition into the realm of the more
godly or entities so let's let go of the
idea of reaching or invoking a similar
level of power to defeat Griffith
because there are other mechanisms
available and one of which would be to
revert femto back into his og Griffith
human form if that were to be
accomplished and guts could handle this
no problem I guess the question would be
how and there is this intriguing thought
that it may have to do with the idea
that Griffith sacrifice was never fully
realized as God's and Casca still lived
to this day branded but still highly
unsanitary thread to somehow revert the
process of God handle a lot of that is
dependent on how one views the process
of sacrifice there if anything it may be
as simple as displaying the mental
commitment to go through with it rather
than the actual act itself and as such
just issuing the brand would be enough
regardless of whether or not your
targets died it's a fairly vague idea in
general though and one that would
potentially go against the concept of
fate again which is exactly why that
thought generally excites me but I think
there is a much clearer and more tragic
vulnerability to Griffith which comes in
the form of one of the most enigmatic
presences in the series being the
moonlight boy and the basic theory here
would be a twist on what I suppose now
goes down in history as a Harry Potter
style connection and there's a variety
of thoughts on this matter the most
basic of which is that the life force of
the moonlight boy is directly linked
with that of Griffith and therefore
should you somehow manage to kill the
moonlight boy then that would also
result in the slaying of Griffith which
would probably be one of the more
twisted outcomes that berserk could
present us with because assumedly it
would either be cut so Casca who would
need to make such a decision
another option however is that there is
a much more simple connection to
Griffith the play and in fact the
moonlight boy is the physical embodiment
of him and simply transforms under a
full moon and then seeks out his parents
and some potential evidence for this
idea comes from chapter 358 which is
fairly recent in the grand scheme of
things with Griffith ruminating under
full moon holding his hair and then
saying of course and this night will be
then a dramatic ellipsis and in the next
panel he's gone seemingly having
embarked into the outside world and
there's also been suggestions that
Griffiths hair is turning black in this
particular panel which yeah I can see
initially I think I saw this Powell and
that aspect was kind of meaningless to
me because Muir is a fiend for shading
so when any other character this would
be a pretty pointless examination
however in retrospect on a character
like Griffith this carries a fair bit of
injury because his hair is almost always
portrayed as this pristine heavenly
existence Nura very much draws it with
what I would call the bare minimum of
depth for his particular style and oddly
enough as a result of that it actually
becomes a standout feature which is
artistically brilliant but it also paves
the way for moments like this
where yes it looks like Griffiths hair
is getting a shade darker perhaps even
transforming into the black hair of the
moonlight boy and with this in mind I
really do think the strongest possible
argument at this point is that Griffith
is the moonlight boy which I imagine
opens up a pretty grand vulnerability if
he were to be harmed or killed in that
form despite the fact that the moonlight
boy is obviously exceptionally powerful
in his own right but in another way this
revelation opens up a new path for
Griffiths defeat which would be the idea
of the moonlight boy becoming a
permanent existence and just sealing
Griffith away within himself which is
also potentially the happiest possible
way the berserk could end with guts and
Casca now having a child to raise and
living a relatively normal life as a
family but if Griffith is to be defeated
I am personally pretty damn convinced
that whatever that mechanism of defeat
is it will be tied to the moonlight boy
that doesn't mean our examination ends
here though because non physical methods
of defeat are also very possible and the
most profound one in my eyes would be to
somehow destroy Griffiths dream much
more so than actually physically
destroying him I feel like the loss of
his dream would break the existence of
Griffith because it is the thing that he
is unwaveringly fought for and made each
and every sacrifice possible to achieve
so for all of that effort to come to
naught would be quite something
although the interesting thing about
Griffiths dream is that it's very hard
to actually define it seems fairly
simple at face value
a quiet Kingdom rule Kingdom live
happily ever after possibly as demon God
and maybe it would have been that simple
when he was human but in femto form I
don't think there is any doubt the
kurth's dream has expanded I mean in
theory as the story stands he has
already achieved his original desire but
just how far does his lost extent is he
eventually going to attempt to rule over
the entirety of both the human and
astral world
but in another way I can honestly see
Griffith coming to defeat himself
because perhaps at some stage he comes
to a realization that his quest is
never-ending and his kingdom will
continue to be built into all eternity
never
to satisfy his desire and thus even
though he is one of the most powerful
beings in existence he will come to
accept his loss in this endeavor
no no admittedly that one was a
particularly wanky method of defeat but
we're about to go a layer of wank deeper
by considering the thought that griffith
may have already lost and what do I mean
by that well it's because having become
an agent of de Monte Griffith may have
lost all understanding of his original
dream in this form Griffith may more or
less just be going through the motions
of his former quest never attaining any
sense of satisfaction from his actions
and so in a way he could rule over all
existence but still not feel any sense
of accomplishment or feel anything at
all really and then he may come to the
realization that his human dream was
just used for the sake of causality and
that he is simply another pawn in the
grand game of fate but I don't think any
exploration of this topic would be
complete without discussing the very a
potential option here that we rather
simply do not defeat Griffith berserk
ends with Griffith attaining everything
he ever wanted and there was nothing
that anybody could have ever done to
prevent it it's bleak but definitely
possible however I do think this would
come in the form of a potentially happy
ending which is probably best epitomized
by the fall and comment I received on
the matter step 1 live peacefully with
your new friends and your girlfriend who
just got her memory restored step 2
various question marks step 3 profit and
maybe that's all there is to it guts
moves on from revenge and decides to
live his life for himself else Griffith
does the same would it be a satisfying
ending not enough depends how Miura
pulls it off I don't think it's out of
the question though then there's also
your pile of classic Mimi answers like
get some sick blind girl to play against
him in gungi which i I really appreciate
actually or even you hit him very hard
the trope pretty fun to read but just on
that last one actually something I
haven't touched on purposely in this
video is the potential of defeating
Griffith via the ever staggering magical
abilities of chicane and fantasy because
I just just kind of refused to go down
that path I know that berserk of late
has placed a large focus on their
abilities in particular but the gap in
power is still staggering and the only
other potential I see would be a big old
classic combination of friendship where
the entire group comes together and
somehow allows guts the ability to face
off evenly against Griffith which
certainly my least favorite of any idea
stated in this video and I think I'm
going to resume for getting about two to
three to one I do think it's pretty
amazing though that this one basic
question can produce so many different
options it speaks volumes about the
potential of berserk and how wonderfully
constructed this epic series has been to
this point the fact that we have been
through so so so much and yet we know so
little is a rare find in media generally
when one is over 300 chapters into a
series you tend to have a solid
understanding of the world its
characters and the direction we're
heading in but berserk continues to be a
huge unknown quantity and sitting at
close to the pinnacle of that is mr.
Griffith a character who we may very
well never have a satisfying ending to
and a character that may very well never
have a satisfying ending for himself
either but what do you guys think please
to leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more bizarre
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos we'll even
subscribe to the channel for regular
bouzouki and madness delivered straight
into your YouTube feed but for now this
has been the New World review and I'll
see you next time